[Musique]
l'île de france retrouve désormais le
var et ans dans 20 % des cas positifs
contre 2% il ya encore quelques jours à
paris il est même détecté dans 27 % des
cas les français savent compter quand on
leur dit croissance exponentielle ils
ont bien compris que ça doublait tous
les deux jours on rentre dans une
période de fortes turbulences avec le
variant omicron qui se traduit encore
une fois on le voit royaume uni par un
déluge de contamination c'est un rapport
de un indice c'est à dire que si on
prenait le premier virus première vague
on lui donnerait un le delta on lui
donnerait trois et le micro dans les dix
l'allemagne vient de prendre une
nouvelle série de décisions elles ont
été annoncés il ya quelques instants à
partir du 28 décembre les personnes
vaccinées ou guéris pourront accueillir
chez elle dix invités maximum les
non-vaccinés devront se limiter à deux
personnes par foyer signe que les choses
s'accélèrent on apprend l'instant que le
projet de passer ni terre le pass
vaccinale pardon sera présenté la
semaine prochaine en conseil des
ministres ce qui pourrait accélérer sa
mise en application
il nous visons désormais une adoption
définitive du pass vaccinale dès la
première quinzaine du mois de janvier
filippo tout pout tout passe vaccinale
vous êtes pour ou contre dans des
contraintes vous êtes contre le post
vaccinales contre pas actional contre
l'obligation de vacciner à arras est
vrai que c'est pas forcément facile à
gérer parce qu'on est pour la
vaccination en fait on avait ces pauvres
il fallait aller tout de suite vers
l'obligation vaccinale universel
peut-être nous aurions pu prendre des
décisions peut-être impopulaire en cette
veille d'élection présidentielle mais
sûrement plus efficace j'ai donc une
puce implantée dans mon bras et je les
programmes et de façon à ce que mon pass
sanitaire soit dessus
cela signifie qu'il est toujours
accessible pour moi ou pour toute autre
personne qui veut le lire vous êtes
accusé d'avoir menti sur votre état de
santé après un test positif au co vie de
19 c'est libération qui l'écrit ce matin
nicolas dupont aignan mise au point par
une entreprise suédoise spécialisée dans
les implants un micro puce elle permet à
ses détenteurs de montrer leur qr codes
s'en sortir leur smartphone de leur
poche j'attaque en justice parce que je
n'accepte pas qu'on essaye de me salir
comme ça absolument abominable non
seulement j'ai été malade mon épouse
aussi on va mieux et en plus on subit la
diffamation de journalistes en fait
qu'ils veulent sans doute me nuire
laurent wauquiez prive l'établissement
de 100000 euros sur les 15 millions
nécessaires à son budget annuel sciences
po grenoble est depuis trop longtemps
dans une dérive idéologique et
communautariste inacceptable c'est
l'impunité totale et l'encouragement de
ce fait pour tous les étudiants de l'iut
de faire pareil avec le prochain
professeur qui dira des choses qui leur
plairont pas à l'origine de cette
suppression la suspension pour quatre
mois de claus kienzler le professeur
d'allemand dénoncé par des étudiants
militants valérie pécresse qui
s'inquiètent de ce phénomène que tu
décris pascal et eric zemmour qui salue
la décision de laurent wauquiez ont
réagi zemmour pour nous c'est un
fasciste déjà alors un bakchich
tranquille sur plateau il a invité un
peu partout il dit tranquillement batou
zahnd et des autres et nous on pense que
c'est ça le sait idéologiquement c'est
le fascisme après c'est pas parce que
j'y sois extrêmement chaud c'est bon non
la vérité c'est que vous êtes un
militant de l'écriture inclusive pas du
tout si puisque votre mouvement
s'appelle les gens engagés gérer ge a
expliqué
vous fumez même pas vous êtes obsédé je
suis pas mais je suis content cette
commune sur la ligne de départ
départager donc par les internautes qui
ont pu voter à chaque tour est le grand
gagnant fin du suspense et sainte verge
faverges dans les succès des engagés
votre mouvement est écrit en défensive
chaque enfant c'est quand même
incroyable de ses positions assumer mais
non je n'assume pas sa nouvelle piste
est imposée en finale face à gland alors
quand il y en a un peu partout en france
mais là c'est gland dans l'yonne